most people have heard the word
gerrymandering once or twice probably
during a presidential election what
exactly is gerrymandering essentially
it's the process of giving one political
party and advantage over another
political party by redrawing district
lines
it's like Democrats trying to gain an
advantage over Republicans or
Republicans trying to gain an advantage
over Democrats you see each party wants
to gain as many districts as possible so
they can do things like control the
state budget or set themselves up to win
even more districts in the future so to
understand how this process began and
how it continues today we must go back
to 1812 in Massachusetts Elbridge Gerry
the governor of Massachusetts supported
and signed a bill to allow redistricting
that is redrawing the boundaries that
separate districts the catch the new
lines would favor Gerry's own political
party the Democratic Republican Party
which no longer exists you see Gerry
wanted his party to win as many state
Senate seats as possible the more
members of your party who vote the more
likely you are to win an election the
new lines were drawn to include loads of
areas that would help Governor Jerry in
the future they were so strange-looking
that someone said the new districts look
like a salamander the Boston Gazette
added Gerry's name to the word
salamander and voila gerrymandering the
process of dividing up and read wrong
districts to give your political party
an advantage so how exactly does someone
go about protecting their own political
party and actually gerrymandering a
district there are two successful
practices packing a district and
cracking a district packing is the
process of drawing district lines and
packing in your opponent's like cattle
into as few districts as possible if
more districts equals more votes the
fewer the districts there are the fewer
votes the opposition party will get
packing then decreases the opponent's
voter strength and influence cracking is
the opposite taking one district and
cracking it into several pieces this is
usually done in districts where your
opponent has many supporters
cracking spreads these supporters out
among many districts denying your
opponent a lot of votes when you have a
large number of people who would
generally vote for one type of party
those folks are known as a voting bloc
cracking as a way to break that all up
so when would a party choose to pack
their opponents districts rather than
crack them well that really depends on
what the party needs to dilute your
opponents voters you could pack them
into one district and leave the
surrounding districts filled with voters
of your own party or if you and your
party are in power when it's time to
redraw district lines you could redraw
districts and crack up a powerful
district and spread your opponent's
voters out across several neighboring
districts so Governor Jerry in 1812
wanted to gain an advantage for his
party and redrew district lines in a
state in such a crazy way we have a
whole new word and way of thinking about
how political parties can gain
advantages over their opponents
politicians think of creative ways to
draw districts every few years so the
next time an election comes around and
politicians ask people to vote be sure
to look up the shape of your district
and the districts that surround it how
why does your district stretch across
your state are all the districts in your
state relatively the same shape how many
other districts does your district touch
but always be sure to ask yourself does
my district look like a salamander
Oh